are you trying starting before I want to
divide your hair is tree even pieces and
then you just go to class your other
strands over the middle I can't even put
the hair in a tie not thing now my wrist
is trapped I'm gonna go under with that
one even just the the grabbing three
strands a hair is vexing me feel it I
want the third hand to hold that third
one this is [ __ ] hard I think I'm
doing it I'm doing it I think is that
look good you go one over the middle and
hold it too over them over pull hold
over that just looks like I rolled it up
God read through this we're gonna get it
right you're gonna make my hair
beautiful look at this
I am Katniss Everdeen this is harder
than I am a CT is so frustrating I can't
do it easy first braids knocked it out
of the park it's three even pieces and
you're gonna cross the right strand over
the middle
on the left are the over the middle
we're gonna separate it into three even
strands which in my case is just
whatever that can get ahold of how is
she doing this how do you even grab just
some of your hair I want to cry this is
just too much
AHA this is the secret you braid it in
the front of your head and then you you
flip it backwards and then you take it
and then you cross under the middle and
then you take it and you say get you
just start tying it it's like the hair
is like bleeding with itself and just
multiplying French braids are [ __ ]
and it's never gonna work it's never
gonna work I give up
I quit I can't do it I understand why
women do like lazy updos now yeah what
if I just took this that looks not
natural the worst